hey thanks JC late night is when the
magic happens Alexis Park Resort Hotel
is hosting a show every Friday and
Saturday at 11 PM to set the mood to
magical Optical Illusionist Bizarro and
sleight of hand Master Madre they're
here to show us and tell us more welcome
guys hey how's it going welcome to the
show we were just talking about we
should all just Elevate so we're all the
same height today huh
well just edit me out later I love it
well welcome to the show you guys let's
talk about what the difference is
between a magic show and a late night
magic show late night magic show where
our show is the only
um late night uh magic show 11 p.m
adults only so 18 and up there we go
I love that now what kind of magic are
we experiencing here with this uh it's
all sorts of magic we've got comedy
we've got a little bit of freaky
Sideshow we've got visual Magic got
crazy sleight of hand yeah
which is nice
I was pulling out a rope there we go
okay what's Happening Here There we go
piece of Rope two ends one Center
interior Center's here
the enemy pair of scissors
yes we do not want to get in a fight
with a pair of scissors we're going to
cut the rope okay
so it gives me two pieces two equal
pieces of rope wait a minute this one's
a little shorter yeah yeah oh wait a
minute let's start from the beginning
okay
one piece of rope wait a minute
[Applause]
what's going on I was like okay let me
see what he does here what he's gonna do
it a bit differently this time this time
I'm gonna tie the rope uh-huh like so so
it gives me one long Loop okay cut with
the magic scissors this time
because there's now are his fingers what
on Earth short piece long piece look
they're not here I can make a jump from
here to here on three one two three
amused but not a mage here we go Madre
professional magician to actually take
the knot slide it there actually pop it
off that leaves me with a little piece
of knot a long piece of rope and that's
the fabulous rope oh my gosh okay this
is crazy let's go with you bizarre we've
got we've got about 40 seconds I brought
something in here for the people at home
can do it's very simple you take some
glue light hold on
awesome no no here's what you do you go
home and what you do is you pour some of
this into your hand like this you
squeeze really tight
it turns back into a horse okay
now I get why this is the Late Night
show this is freaky okay how do we get
tickets
uh you go to magiclateknight.com and you
can there you go right there on the
graphic you can see and uh ticket.com I
believe is the website to get tickets
from yeah 11 o'clock Friday and Saturday
it's gonna expect to see you there again
thank you both for joining us thank you
for having us
all right crazy stuff there well